Welcome
back.
We're ready to do part
D, and let me copy and
paste that in as well.
See, I don't think that's going
to need this graph, so let
me just remove that with a
color other than yellow.
It's copy and pasted.
I don't know if you can read
it, but it's helpful for me
to review the problem
on our clipboard.
OK.
The rate at which tickets were
sold for t -- for over this
range is modeled by r of t--
let me write that in case you
can't see it-- is the rate at
which tickets were sold. r of t
is equal to 550 te to the minus
t over 2 tickets per hour.
Based on the model, how many
tickets were sold by 3:00 PM?
So my t equals 3-- to the
nearest whole number?
So that's sometimes important.
You don't want to give
a decimal answer.
So this is the rate at
which tickets are sold.
So this is the derivative
of the total tickets
sold function.
Or another way that we could
write it is the total tickets
sold-- so let's call that, I
don't know, capital T sub--
well let me-- I don't want to
do T of t, that's
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So let's say the tickets sold
as a function of time is going
to be equal to the definite
integral-- well, we could say
is at any time t, the tickets
sold-- and this is the
fundamental theorems calculus,
I think it might be one of its
correlaries or actually
sometimes it is the fundamental
theorem of calculus, I always
forget my definitions.
Between time equals 0 and t--
or if we want to know the
tickets sold, between time
equals 0 and t is equal to the
integral of the rate at which
the tickets sold was changing.
So that's equal to 550te
to the minus t over 2dt.
Right?
That's it.
And so if we want to know how
many tickets were sold at time
equals 3, that's just equal to
the definite integral from 0 to
3, or we could also view it as
the area under this curve, from
time equals 0 to time equal to
3 of 550te to the
minus t over 2dt.
Now this integral right here,
you can solve it analytically
using integration of parts,
which I just called the reverse
product rule, but you only have
45 minutes to do all three of
these problems, and they'll let
you use your graphing
calculator, and your graphic
calculator is excellent at
doing definite integrals, and
they just want the
number, right?
So let's use our graphic
calculators to get that number.
Let's see.
I don't want to copy,
so how do we do that?
We just do second the division
button but that's calc--
definite, let me use the
definite integral, and like
what was, let's see, let me
make sure I have that--
550 let's just use x.
550 times x times second e to
the minus x divided by 2.
I think that's the
whole function.
And let's see.
My independent variable is x,
I've just swapped t for x
there, and I'm taking the
integral from 0 to 3.
Click enter, let the
calculator do the work.
This would have taken you quite
a while if you had to actually
do the integral yourself.
972.78, and they want
us to round to the
nearest whole number.
So the nearest whole
number is 973.
So we say 973 tickets
sold by 3:00 PM.
And we're done.
That only took us four minutes.
And it would have taken us
even less if we didn't
have to explain it.
Anyway.
I will see you in
problem number three.